I saw this story down in Orange County
right then in Orange County California
this guy gave helicopter tours for 30
years 30 years without incident hands to
business off to his son the American
dream I built it up for 30 years yeah
you go son
make the family and the family game
proud all right dad I love you right
poor kid five days said he's supposed to
give a tour to a couple only the two
shows up the kid thought it was weird
he's like I need the money I got to give
him a tour right so he takes this guy up
ten minutes into the tour the dude
[ __ ] jumped out yeah five basic five
days in for the balloons and the cake we
love your son family tree going
traditional like five [ __ ] days later
this kid he probably barely had the
speech down just sitting there flying
the helicopter all right if you look out
the left side of the aircraft that's
Orange County it's over 27 miles of
beaches put your seat belt back on 27
miles of beaches was established as a
county in 1903 sir please don't open the
door sir what are you doing
air traffic control I don't know who's
on this frequency but you really did
find a shed so I read further into the
story turns out the guy who jumped out
he was 61 years old terminally ill he
was in pain every day they couldn't
figure out what was wrong with them and
he had had enough at that point that guy
immediately became a hero in my world
right you know what I loved about him
not only did he make the decision he
didn't go out like some [ __ ] right van
full of pills watching a romantic comedy
wrapped in an Afghan that Nana made [ __ ]
that guy went out like a man take me up
in a chopper I'm looking at the land I
love and then I'm jumping out like a
superhero I love it
I should have been wearing a [ __ ]
cape I can't imagine how elated he must
have been on that helicopter ride up
after finally you know just taking back
control of his life like [ __ ] you
disease I decide you know ripping tubes
out gets a burger shotguns a beer take
me up in the chakra put me at his
[ __ ] foot on the dashboard you know
he's not even listening to this guy
giving the tour right over over 27 miles
of Beach
[Applause]
but here's the thing I left out one
small thing there is one small thing the
guy [ __ ] lifting yeah Danny well they
were out over the ocean 500 feet up you
think that would be enough so I'm
thinking he must have gone in like Greg
Louganis like no splashes coop but
witnesses said it looked like a dummy
was falling out of the air so that
sounds like a hell of an impact I think
he accidentally did the most epic
500-foot belly flop and the history of
jumping out of a helicopter you know but
that didn't change what he was trying to
joke where his heart was I still love
this guy I just feel Pat for just on the
way down he's got to be thinking three
more seconds of a second Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh it has a happy ending though
he later died at the hospital
that's right so here Sam god bless them
I hope I have the pulse someday